come on and his Peter others are you
hiding behind their theater here as part
of the privacy semester of course
information theory and information there
are the techniques play a big role in
research on crypto and privacy broadly
but I think the focus of today and
tomorrow is really on research
directions that have been developing in
the information theory community per se
and how they do well and things that
that are relevant to the program that I
think you start coming in with this
other community woman for which there's
not as much contact that's yes so with
Lolita ticket yeah so first I'm gonna
start by thanking Adam and Pete of
object I think that's gonna happen
without Adam a very supportive of this
effort so I'm just going to take about
five fifteen seven minutes to set the
problem and then we'll have the series
of longer talks okay so let's start with
a little hypothetical experiment this is
where I like to start so let's assume
your favorite data collector and they
have access to your browsing history
right and behind every person who
browsers is or every person who browser
has a favorite color that they like
could be blue or red because the
universe is binary and what happens is
really the browser or the person who
collects your browsing history will
appear a curator has only access to this
and what they then wish to do is to
share it because they can with somebody
else that does analytics because they
want to learn something preferably they
want to actually learn your favorite
color right so they release it and voila
turns out that
analytics company can fix your two
favorite colors okay so obviously this
is a problem at least recently and so
one way to fix this problem is to do
something to the data 2d correlate
things that shouldn't be revealed with
things that should be real in this case
color with your browsing history right
so one can call that a privacy mechanism
and broadly a privacy mechanism 50
correlating is a randomizing madness
right so then I released this sort of
there make some changes like you can see
here and that allows hopefully the
analytics company to have a little bit
more uncertainty about your favorite
color at least will bulk of the people
okay so so the problem here is one of
inference or not allowing undesired
inferences so there's an opposing
objective which all of you here I think
know about where you want to share the
data for some hopefully greater good and
then you may have to change distort
randomize the data a little bit to
reduce to to reduce the leakage of
unwanted information right so there's a
there's a conflict between what some
measure of privacy or leaked information
leakage that you want minimize and then
some measure of utility or the value of
the data that you wanna share okay okay
I'm gonna give you another hypothetical
situation because these are the kinds of
things that I think information theory
methods could help address right here's
the data set this is actually the
recidivism data set from Florida's
Broward County and it has people's
information in it about that charges
apply accounts and it has at least this
came from ProPublica which later on
after two years put down the truth later
on they then recidivism right the goal
is to use all this data to predict this
and according to legal discrimination
rules this particularly sensitive
feature which is race shouldn't really
be used to be
this decision right but even if you
remove this perhaps from this data you
can actually figure out what they're
racist for example right so there's
still a problem of making sure that you
share this data for to a learning
algorithm while actually limiting this
kind of correlation okay so can we do
that so one things that this particular
workshop will talk about is what is
information leakage in this context even
mean how do you quantify it and I'll
just go back to a very simple model
which you see over and over again
because the dataset X X may have
associated with it a secret or a
sensitive variable s in this case I'm
working a very support going to say X X
is going to be shared as except you
might see exhale in some place you might
see Y another placement somewhat similar
rank will make it clear there's a very
cool quantity and information theory
it's got information density you give me
an instance iation of X or an available
X and X half I can define information
that says just the log of the posterior
of X given X ID which is release and its
prime right and you could write it in
bottles okay so this leads to a very
classical notion which is if you average
this you get mutual information and this
has been used in discussion Riskin so
very very lot of statisticians used it
it may have fallen out of favor one of
the things we hope to tell you is where
it may be useful and if you really work
with this a little bit more and you
rewrite it you actually get a local
differential first right were you taking
a supermoon now over every possible X
and exact as well as over the
distribution of X but
there's gonna be a whole bunch of things
in between what is the adversarial model
if you say mutual information are the
measures that span from you to
information to look at a differential
privacy because one was averaging the
other words worst case overall possible
distributions and that's sort of what
this whole symposium is going to be
about talk to you about how do you talk
about a bunch of measures what is the
measure perhaps you should use in
different contexts maybe it's privacy
maybe it's security and how should the
utility define how you think the measure
and mechanism and what are the I
preserve one of the things we really
hope you take away is or the episode of
assumptions or the underlying model of
each measure okay and how are these
measures related one simple thing I
would like for at least another thing
I'd like you to keep in mind as we do
this is to observe that if you're seeing
averaging over a measure you somehow
implicitly you have knowledge of the
statistics show you context-aware right
so on other hand some of these
worst-case statistics could be lower
worst case measures could be looked at
as context-free they are agnostic to say
the distribution what should be the
right measure to use a different
constant I don't know if we can talk
about all of that but it is something
you should think about when we talk
about this measure right
sometimes context-aware may actually
help even in the worst case model like
recently koala cos work on releasing
graphs as shown so something to think
about right and one of the things that
you will take away from hopefully the
whole bunch of talks here is the
additional models that you'll see are
very closely related to learning theory
analysis are they presumably weaker ad
versus that's a question to think about
and when you relax any measure with its
P or some other measure what is the
corresponding adversary hopefully we can
make that connection right I'd like to
leave you with one analogy and that's
the following so there's crypto and I'd
like to think of RSA as as a as a an
implementation of crypto for a current
atmosphere and water which as you cannot
factor large numbers right in real time
and perhaps some of the measures that we
talked about can we look that is
learning the theoretic adversaries of
loving adversaries that perhaps are
strong enough for today's architectures
in practice right so I'm going to these
are the things that I want you to take
away from this whole symposium how we
apply it to safe fairness and we'll also
show you how to actually design some of
these mechanism that come from these
measures using generative adversary
models okay so I'm going to just dive
into our four speakers five speakers and
Wagner is our first speakers going next
he's an information theorist forgot one
of these best under-40 information
theory so he's really of information
theory and he'll be talking about a very
very motivated measure for leakage which
is maximum leakage and that we have
flowery areas from Cornell flowers from
Harvard he is going to he uses
information theory methods to study both
privacy and fairness today he's going to
talk about fairness tomorrow he's going
to have another talk about connecting
information bottleneck methods and so on
to information of attitude to privacy
problems and then you have Kairos who is
now at Google who is at Stanford before
and then UI in Singapore that and Google
feel is going to talk about her films
how do you generate models to actually
design privacy mechanisms and he's also
going to talk about some theoretical
guarantees on how adversaries can learn
from what finite capacity advertising
who make all that
can learn from any mechanism that you
used to design it to release it it's
okay
and tomorrow we have Kiwanuka coming in
from UCSD and she's going to talk about
methods to compare inferential and
differential privacy yeah and that's all
right so I'm gonna stop here and let
Aaron take I'm just going to give a chop
[Music]
turn up the lighting sorry this will
turn up these lights or this is right as
it gets want to start pressing stuff
randomly but here we go
thank you okay alright so thank you oh
we thought for for inviting me and thank
you to the Simon's staff or for
organizing this so yeah I'm gonna talk
about a particular metric called Maxima
leakage and I've I've ever got this
metric in his various forms for quite a
while so I'm doing a lot of talks on
this over the years and I know there are
some people here in the audience who've
seen like end versions of this talk
where n is quite large but you know
given the nature of the workshop I
thought I would kind of start from the
beginning and go slow and you know we
can be interactive I can speed up you
know if if necessary so let me start by
acknowledging my collaborators
collaboration with four people so the
early part of the work on the
development of the metric and
theoretical properties was on
collaboration with Ibrahim Issa who was
a PhD student at Cornell at the time now
a faculty at American diversity of
Beirut and also Sudeep comma was a
postdoc at Princeton at the time and now
on Wall Street and more recently been
looking at applying this metric to
particular site channels in computing
systems and that work his collaboration
with Ben Wu who's a PhD student at
Cornell and my colleague ed saw who's a
computer architect specializing in
security okay so this work originated in
a study of side channels in in computing
systems so the metric was sort of
conceived with that application in mind
the metrics potentially applicable
beyond that original application but
that was our original motivation and I
will describe the work in that context a
side channel for me is just any any
medium that communicates information
unintentionally or inadvertently so it's
question of intent so by that definition
that if you said channel is bad but
we're mostly interested in the side
channels that are problematic and
especially those that arise in computing
systems so we had two side channels that
we in mind that we use as motivating
examples so I'll give these to you just
to be concrete so when is the SSH timing
side channel
brought to the fore by song at all okay
so I think people still use SSH but I
use it a lot so it's just for those who
don't know it's a terminal you know
Interactive terminal program and the
idea is I can get my laptop here I can
SSH if use it as a verb to a computer
back at Cornell and you know I can
interact you know at the command line
and the way the protocol works is after
the initial handshake when you're an
interactive mode every time I press the
key on my on my laptop it sends a packet
out saying what key I pressed and
therefore the timing of the packets is
correlated with the timing of the
keystrokes and this is a problem because
the timing the keystrokes is known to be
correlated with way I'm typing right
so although the packets are encrypted
you know the timing of the packets is
leaking information about what I'm
typing so you know if I type my password
someone could you know measure the time
of these packets mean information about
my password and then try to launch some
kind of you know guessing an attack the
other one is the RSA it's it's also a
time inside channel the RSA decryption
channel
this is culture six okay so the idea
here is that for some implementations of
RSA the decryption time is key dependent
okay so if an adversary can measure the
the decryption time it can glean
information about the key and actually
kosher describes this attack I find very
clever that allows the attacker to kind
of learn the key bit by bit by timing
different decryptions with different
ciphertext okay so those are two
concrete side channels there many others
that people have looked at these are two
that we had a miner began this work so
so these boards go all the way down to
the floor I don't know how low I can
about there okay like knee high right at
the strike zone okay so up there okay so
so the test we looked at is how do you
how do you send strategies that mitigate
these kinds of attacks so you can
imagine like you know randomly delaying
the announcement of the of the
computation and RSA decryption some in a
random out of time in order to thwart
this this attack or likewise here you
could kind of hold the the packet inside
the client for some amount of time
before you send it out and you'd like to
do you know do the delay in a way that
kind of mitigates these attacks and so
how do you do that what's a good
strategy okay so if you need a metric
right need a way of quantifying how much
are you leaking and there are lots of
metrics out there that one can use but
mutual information is probably the first
thing that comes to mind if your
intervention theorist but we'd like
something kind of operational something
that really quantify is like how
susceptible is the the the design to
these kinds of attacks
okay so certainly I mean there are lots
of just kind of general measures of
correlation out there that you can just
kind of apply and optimize and stuff but
we'd like to be a little more
operational about it so this is the
metric we came up with
just a setup I'm gonna use why instead
of X hat I will use ass okay so first of
all warning so in all of our work we
always use you for this for this
workshop and I try to use s given that's
the standard notation and all the other
talks I'll try my best
I'm a little bit worried I'm going to
slip back into you without even
realizing it so you know just a warning
if you hear you just replace it with us
okay so s is the the secret the
sensitive quantity okay so over here it
might be like the password the other
thing I'm typing here might be the key X
is the nominal process so it might be
you know the the time the nominal packet
timings you know as their as the packets
are produced by the ssh client or here
would be the actual execution time for
decryption and then why is revealed is
what the average state would see and so
you know at a high level it's like you
know s is sort of given that's we have
no control over X is kind of given but
we're choosing py given X that's the
mechanism that we're we're taking okay
all right so we'd like to kind of
capture how much is being leaked in
these kinds of applications so let me
give you the definition
we're gonna build this up step by step
so it's gonna be a function of the Joint
Distribution of X and y and we'll say
the maximum leakage maximal leakage next
y is the following so they build this up
in stages okay so I'm going to look at
how well the average so you can guess s1
has access to Y this is just a map
probably of correct detection of s from
y okay I'm gonna normalize that by the
chance the adversary guesses s without
access to anything just you know the
single largest probability in @p method
s all right so this is like the
multiplicative change in the probably of
guessing s so when the adversary has Y
versus when it has nothing okay and you
know already we're making a design
choice here we think the multiplicative
increase is the right way of measuring
the change here because we're in stood
in things like passwords where the a
priori probably have guessing is very
small so this might be 10 to my 16 all
right this might be like 10 to minus 7
right so the ratio rather the difference
is the relevant relevant scale
we'll take log ok so you know in words
it's probably have guessing the password
goes up by a factor of four we'll say we
lost we leaked two bits
and here's the really key step okay so
we're gonna assume that we don't know
the distribution between s and X someone
takes a premium overall s that's fine I
should explain this notation this is the
arrow notation clear this is a
conditional dependent statement
okay so s and y are conditionally kind
of given X then I write these arrows
it's just a notation okay so this this
means Y and s are independent given X
Daniel practice is not hard to affect
okay because I'm I'm usually designing Y
from X if that's my mechanism so I just
ensure that that ran this is independent
everything else and then automatically I
get I get this condition okay so here
the we're gonna be this as a function of
XY and the idea is we don't know the the
s that the adversary is after so you
take supreme over all s okay i guess you
can motivate multiple ways actually you
can say you know either qualitatively we
don't know what secret the adversary is
after maybe it's after a pass through
payments after a key who knows it could
be that qualitatively we know what it's
after it's after the key or it's after
what we're typing or whatever we just
don't know the distribution between s
and X so we just take worst case all
right
so so this part here is a function you
know in the square brackets as a
function of the joints tribution of sx
and you but i supreme out a supreme
amount s yes yes correct this one or
this one it's a function overall yeah
overall guessing algorithms correct you
didn't take the soup over s you'd get
some like okay this one if you if you
just if s were X then you'd get
something closer to like min entropy
loss or something we will talk about
that variant in a bit well anyway you
any thing about exit wanted to predict
yeah any any randomized function of s so
inwards the way I interpret this is that
like you know if if the leakage of X to
Y is 3 bits and
means the adversaries chance of guessing
any randomize function of s increases by
no more than a factor of eight when it
observes Y compared to when it did not
have why it's so SEO is like the
randomized function of X s is the
randomize function yeah so you know so
just think of s is you know f of X where
f is a randomized function yeah exactly
okay so definition okay
okay so I think one virtue of this
definition is that it's you know it's
clearly operational like you know if the
number is three bits I have a you know
an operational way of interpreting that
bound when downside of this definition
is that's not clear you can compute it
because like I put no constraints on s
here at all doesn't even clear this
things like decidable right there are
standard ways of making a quantity like
this computable in information theory if
x and y are discrete the standard trick
is that you try to bound this the
necessary support size of s to receive
the premium in terms of these
alphabetizes okay and then once you do
that then okay it's all just finite
dimensional worst case you just grid the
whole thing and now it's computable this
turns out to fail here okay so we can
show there are there examples of binary
X&Y that require arbitrarily large
alphabet s in order to approach the
supreme uhm okay so that that trick
using crafty Dory's theorem is out the
window but okay it turns out we can
actually compute this thing simply it
has a simple closed-form solution and we
identify the s that achieves the supreme
them right so
there's the theorem so if x and y are
discrete I'll do the discrete case there
are continuous analogs
because from X to Y is log this log is
just this log okay so if you don't like
this log you can delete it and then you
just don't have this log here okay so
nothing is dependent on the log being
there
okay log sum over Y max over X any
support
okay so if you think of the mechanism is
a stochastic matrix okay then you're
just summing up the kind of maximum
column entry a maximum of each column
subject to this support constraint okay
just hang those up and taking those okay
so fill out the rest of the talk I'm
just gonna assume X is full support okay
if X is not I mean you know it's not in
type of clear what this even means you
know for an X that doesn't have a
positive probability I mean in practice
you're often designing this and you
don't so we know it's a port ahead of
time so maybe you pick up py given X you
know a distribution over Y for X's that
don't even arise so I mean that can that
can happen but just to keep the the the
kind of presentation simple which is
assume X has full support in which case
you don't really have that that
condition X
decimal support and also I will assume X
and y or discrete throughout the rest of
the talk with one exception that will be
clear at the end I won't keep writing
these these assumptions okay so two
notes about the theorem
okay so one is the maximum Likud is
actually independent of substitution of
Acts okay I mean formally I guess you
say it depends on next to its support
own way but you know if you assume has
full support then beyond that support
assumption missing does not depend on px
at all okay which is which is not a sin
practice right in practice you know
typically we control py given X we're
designing that so we know that px is
less clear right I mean that's the
timing it's like the distribution of
packet timings or decryption timing
these things can be hard to estimate in
practice so it's nice that the metric
does not depend in a very sensitive way
on that and that's just kind of a you
know a kind of happy accident in the
sense that the original definition you
know formally it depends on P X Y
together right and it so happens that
the dependence on px falls out
okay so formally it depends on the joint
P X Y in fact though it only depends on
the the marginal to this right hand side
has a name in the information three
literature is called sips and mutual
information of order infinity so
probably everyone's familiar with the
rényi generalization of Shannon entropy
you can ask like what's the analogous
generalization of Mitchell information
there isn't really one generalization
that you know people are agreed on as
like the natural generalization of
mutual information Simpson has one there
are others so sips input for the whole
family of mutual information quantities
and there's an order parameter you've
got the order go to infinity then you
get then you get that it's not a
completely new quantity all right
the the proof I can is like three lines
plus the identification of the s we can
do that or we can skip and jump to
properties do it
alright so fixin s and consider the the
numerator here consider this quantity
it's probably of guessing s correctly
when you have access to Y okay so using
standard calculations and write that as
follows so that's sum over Y s over s
psy and okay now the theorem you know is
in terms of X right x and y so we didn't
bring X in here and use the assumption
that this Markov chain holds so it's
kind of like follow our noses
so let me write this joint as a sum over
X DX
yes given X py given X
yeah I'm eating the Markov chain
condition all right I'm just gonna
maximize this quantity over X Prime
so I can upper bound can clear it's not
that is equal I get an upper bound
okay by just maximizing this over X
prime prime there may be it's hard to
read yeah okay alright and then this can
all get pulled outside of the X I have
some over Y you can get pulled outside
the maximization over s2 you just have
max over X prime py given X Y given X
Prime so that whole rope gets pulled out
and then I have max over s this is
what's left some / XP XP s given X right
that's just
[Music]
that's it for you know the upper bound
right because this is the lower bound or
is the denominator here okay we're not
using the log the log is just because
the quantity kind of naturally is
measured on a logarithmic scale so the
units are logarithmic but the math you
know the log doesn't enter into the math
okay so to complete the proof we just
have to show their existent asks for
which you get a quality here so I'll
just show you the S and and stare at it
to see that it achieves the quality
they're actually for this ass you can
just compute the numerator and
denominator directly and just check that
it gives you the formula that you want
here's the I'll do an example that
illustrates how to choose the S so well
suppose your px is a very particular
example okay
four times three times two tens 1/10 so
texts you know for makes forty four
values each little block represents one
tenth of the probability
okay so I need to map this into a joint
distribution of X and U or X excuse me X
and s all right need a couple an s2 this
here's how we do it so so I'm gonna draw
the joint pmf for X and U and you know
the X values will be the rows the S
values will be the columns okay so what
you do is you take the smallest take a
smallest probability for x map that to
one particular value for one particular
s X pair so that goes here yeah this is
just a generic construction that works
for all yes okay so there is a generic
construction that works for all X I
think this particular construction is
easy as explained by doing one
particular example and then it'll
hopefully be clear how to generalize it
so maybe just humor me for this one
example and then we'll see how to sure
okay
all right so so take the smallest you
know positive probability for x map that
to a single X X pair okay take take the
next highest probability of X in this
case the probably is twice this one I'm
going to take these two little pieces of
probability and map them to two
different values of s that are different
from this first one but they're the same
X so they go here
okay and then this through these three
and in draw this quick to scale get
mapped to different values of s all the
same value of x and then so you're
making X uniform we're making so X is an
X is fixed we don't get to play with X
but we're making s uniform yeah exactly
we call it shattering I don't know if it
had a name prior to but you're sort of
taking the mass for X and just
shattering it into a bunch of shards and
each of these shards gets mapped to a
different opinion as yeah okay I'm sure
probably comes up other places yeah
so okay so in general you know the
probabilities for X are not integer
multiples of the smallest one but in
that case you know it turns out as long
as as long as you have one of these
shards for each value of x is equal to
this one the other ones can be smaller
so if this one ends up being half you
know or this one's 2/3 that that's
that's fine so you can handle any
distribution in that way okay so they
can't be bigger I shouldn't draw it that
way any smaller so no bigger than okay
so what ends up happening is that like
you know in this case s is s is uniform
or nearly uniform okay and X is a
deterministic function of s and that is
that's what it sieves the supreme um
here in this example you can either
compute I mean it's not hard to compute
just the numerator denominator directly
and then show it hits the upper bound or
if you kind of stare at this you
convince yourself that it's giving you a
quality and that inequality alright so
one virtue of this this proof is that it
shows that the s that achieves the
premium is not some like totally wild
thing in fact in some of the
applications that we've looked at this
ass is precisely the s that you care
about you know in the RSA example for
instance the decryption time is a
determinate function of the key if the
ciphertext is known if you treat the key
is uniform okay if you're willing to do
that then
the key itself achieves the supremum
okay so this in that example there's no
worry that this is a you know grossly
pessimistic quantity
so the kid said achieves because the
keys sought a constructor in that
fashion what is it the key satisfied to
this really
he's uniform in their Krypton time is it
terms a function of the key exactly yeah
and that's what achieved the supreme um
in this case
okay so some properties from the theorem
you know some of these you could
potentially argue directly from the
definition but you know they follow the
room so one is we call data processing
data processing inequality so if X Y Z
forms a Markov chain so Z is like a post
processed version of X from X to Z is
upper bounded by both the leakage from X
to Y and the leakage from Y
horse processing only reduces leakage
self leakage
x2 itself
just log of the support size
so really peer and they're variable and
I just hand it to you the Maxima leakage
would say I've leaked one bit for any P
minus P is not zero one I mean it's you
know we know just from the just by
looking at the theorem I can't depend on
P right goes depending as long as it's
full support
so all Bernoulli peas have to leak the
same amount and they all weak one bit so
already we see it like a qualitative
difference with mutual information your
salvation would depend on P alright if
you combine these two you get the
leakage from X to Y is upper bounded by
log of the support sides for X and for y
so as an information theorist as this is
appealing to me in that like it shows
that leakage kind of exists on the same
natural scale as I can't repeat mutual
information right it's not negative
right and then you know it's no more
than log of it sighs yes I'm not I mean
the leakage is just defined for any Y
right now when you are applying this and
you're designing a mechanism right then
certainly you could pick Y and for any
choice of Y alphabet then you know this
thing is well defined even computing me
ask what's a good alphabet to use yeah
the question about like why maybe this
is a historical question why is why why
do you sort of approach the problem from
the beginning as defining linkages like
a property of this pair of random
variables x and y rather than defining
it as a property at the channel the
conditional probabilities right you said
like though we define leakage at look
it's cool fact it's a feature only of
the channel mm-hmm the thing you wanted
at the beginning was not actually a
feature of the channel it was a feature
of the pair and it just like yes I'm
just curious is it was there like a
reason for that or is that a you know
historical accident or just you know an
artifact of presentation or like living
no I'm being sincere in the sense that
like we didn't we identified the
definition first as the thing that we
cared about and like you know we want to
be able to kind of make guarantees about
how well the average that I can guess
these hidden functions so that was so we
had the definition first and we said you
know if this ends up the paint on px
then so be it
I guess we'll have to learn P of X but
this is the quantity that we really care
about and then then we prove the theorem
and it so happened it didn't depend on P
X but like if it did hypothetically like
we lived in some alternate universe
where the thing depend on P X then I
would say by golly I guess we're going
to P X to use this because the
definition that definition is what we
care about in our application yeah I
think it's your question sure
yeah okay yeah other questions
so the definition could be look that
isn't happy cereal strategy because
there's a threat model implicit in the
definition which is that the adversary
wants to guess as we want to make it
hard for the office area to guess s and
you know exactly what s the adversaries
after and so we take supremo the
definition doesn't yeah it does include
Omega it doesn't you give me anything
the definition is an adversary of Mordor
in my mind because it tells me what the
other to do without you do they and what
the best it can do with that release but
I don't know I don't want to take too
much your time so we can discuss it
offline so this notion has appeared
without this notation but that is OK in
crypto people have looked at something
called min entropy loss which is like
the version of this where s is equal to
X uh-huh and then sort of said ok but
now what we really want to prove is like
the maximum in entropy loss over all
distributes yes yes it ends up this is
like a much cleaner way of encapsulating
I think what has gone happened
implicitly in like in a bunch of talk
about that definition actually will talk
about some variations of this including
including I I think the one that you're
referring to
ok so last one
leakage from X to Y is 0 if and only if
X is independent of Y so he's not
negative but it's 0 if and only if
they're independent and when one comment
here is that if you impose the
constraint that s is a deterministic
function of X you get a different metric
that metric does not have this property
if I change the definition so that s
must be f of X or F is deterministic ok
you get a different metric and that
metric has the property that the leakage
can be 0 if and only when X is dependent
with Y and to me this is sort of
axiomatic like you know any reasonable
metric should have this property so it
kind of speaks to the importance of
having the randomized
they're randomized s okay we've looked
at various variations of this theme so
different variations on the definition
the definition turns out to be rather
robust okay and that like you know
different permutations of the definition
tend to give the same computable
characterization doing one that Adam
mentioned so I'll mention a few of these
I won't do them in detail so one is
multiple guesses where it's not
mathematically if if need be let me just
try to do it in words so in the
definition of maximal leakage the
adversary gets one guess right okay
without why it gets one guess and
without with why it gets one guess right
and you know it succeeds of it guess is
correct
and it fails otherwise I can send her a
variation where they adversary gets K
guesses in both cases okay it gets K
guesses with no why and it gets K guess
is with Y okay and if any one of the K
gets is this correct then it wins and if
all K guesses are correct then it loses
and what's the multiplicative increase
in the chance that it wins
you know when has access to Y versus not
okay you can call that maybe L sub K
will be kids with K guesses okay and the
theorem is that that equals the maximum
leakage with one guess
it's robust to the number of guesses no
no independent okay okay it's the ratio
this is the ratio they feel yes yeah
it's yeah
where the s needs to change right i
mean--if use this ass there's only so
many different values of s and once K is
bigger than that then it becomes a
generous so the K needs to Kennish the s
needs to shatter more as K grows but the
ratio ends up being the same approximate
guessing
what is your definition of le I can I
can write it yeah so yeah you the
adversary gets K chances its K guesses
and success for the adversary is if any
one of the K guesses is correct and
you've changed both the numerator and
denominator right I mean both with and
without Y you get K guesses realizing
the fact that it's the worst case of her
s here right because like presumably
what you do is you're gonna like shatter
s by an extra factor yeah right
and so yeah I argue the original
definition is heavily dependent on the
worst case thing is not the K all right
approximate guessing so you can
stipulate that s is a random variable
from some metric space and the adversary
I guess is a point in the metric space
and if it's guess is within a certain
distance of the true s it wins and if
it's not inside you know unit ball
around the two s then it loses and you
can format the problem that way and you
get the same money back as long as the
metric space is sufficiently rich metric
space has only one point in it you know
then there's do assuming it's rich
enough you get the same same answer
general gains
okay so rather than saying the adversary
you know is wins if it gets that you
know return 1 if it guesses the s
correctly and 0 otherwise I can imagine
is having some gain function they're
just given the s and the S hat just
spits out with adversaries gain is and
one put one particular choice would be
one if they're equal and zero otherwise
but I could have this nar betray gain
function all right I can phone out the
problem as before where I have just the
expected increase sorry the ratio of the
increase in expected gain when you have
access to y versus not it takes a
premium overall gain functions and you
get the same thing back you get the
mutual information of order infinity
back so it's so in sometimes though you
know the worst-case gain is this zero
one gain that amounts are just guessing
s
so next one let me do in in detail
because I think this is what Adam was
referring to if I understood correctly
yes - yeah just that like s lives in a
metric space and if s hats the
adversaries guess is within distance one
of the true s then the adversary wins
otherwise it doesn't so doesn't have to
guess s correctly just some distance to
a special case of three probably yeah
yeah I mean I mean there's like a
one-sided argument right like this
should be bigger than that cuz you can
capture this with this but it's not
clear that they're all equal yeah yeah
yeah
yeah I mean all these are generalization
of the original one but the point is
that these generalizations don't
increase the thing at all they all give
you the same computable quantity back
we're guessing X this one will do in
detail so I can define I used like
subscript I for self here so I'm gonna
find a similar quantity where we just
lock X to be equal to sorry we lock s to
be equal to X so there's no use X hat
here instead of s hat
okay it's just choosing s to be equal to
X right this will depend on the
distribution for X you could imagine
maximizing that out
okay and the claim is that this two
gives you the let me not write it
actually that way because for visas will
be clear in a moment let me write out
the formula
so if we only care about guessing X but
we maximize over the description for X
you get the same quantity back so this
is this is equal to just the regular
maximum we get your next to Y right this
theorem is not ours Ron when I'm
building on some some earlier work come
up and Smith alright the history is we
developed our metric we you know proved
our theorem we started well it seems
pretty basic pretty fundamental sure
this is done before we did this like
really exhaustive literature search we
didn't find it that remarkable okay we
barged ahead and you know approved all
these like subsidiary theorems and so on
and then stumbled upon this and said oh
this is this is it's kind of known
already not exactly the you know there
our theorem does not imply there's
there's not imply or it's a slight
different set up I think you know given
the choice okay I'm very biased okay
given the choice I actually prefer our
notion of the definition because it
allows you to make guarantees about
hidden quantities you know randomized
functions of like the applications we
cared about the RSA thing the SSH the
adversary I wasn't really interested in
guessing X itself right yesterday
doesn't care about packet timings it
doesn't care about completion times but
it cares about keys and passwords and
stuff so that's what we want to protect
and if here's our definition then you
know then I mean okay using our
definition you can kind of make a
guarantee about how well those things
are protected and this theorem does not
provide that as I stated here it's only
a statement about X itself right so
when you take the soup over PX isn't it
also closed under this broth under
process and handling so you could the
channel from s to Y and get-go angle
from the keyboard is part of just part
of the channel that question it was a
question yeah there's the question
this notion not closed under data
processing it's the same expression so
you know the properties that we had I
mean that those would all hold for this
one too right because it's the same I
guess the questions like do you have to
you given that they're equivalent you
ultimately get the same thing yeah it
gives anything yeah exactly
there's some the different different
definitions same computable
characterization so in practice like you
this is what you really use anyway is
this thing right so it's like you know
our theorem kind of provides a extra
support for using this quantity as the
thing that you're you're minimizing they
in the CS security literature like in
these papers this is actually called
maximal leakage okay
that's like purely a coincidence okay
they pick the same name we did which is
very happy for us otherwise we have like
dueling you know terminology for the
same quantity understanding that we
would just fold up our term at that
point since they had it first
all right we can do much time Drive left
15 you can do I might skip there's a
conditional version and from the
conditional version you can get
composition theorems we only have a kind
of a weak composition theorem let's
maybe like to approve improve upon I can
talk about that I can also talk about
how mutual information and local
differential privacy can be explained
using a very similar definition to what
we had for maximal leakage and I talked
about mechanisms like your optimal
mechanisms I can't do all three of those
things to 15 minutes about we do like
one of them what's the what's the
audience preference additional mutual
information differential privacy in this
framework or mechanism definitions these
this relates to other okay mutual
information
so first we're clear on the definition
to mutual information and the ministry
pays so you know very commonly used
metric for leakage and lots of other
things too
so not hard to show first of all that
maximal leakage upper bounds mutual
information always and you can you can
give conditions for win equality holds
they're kind of messy I don't know
they're really that illuminating so I
won't try to write them down this this
ratio actually can be arbitrarily large
even for binary X&Y
okay so if you if you agree that this is
like you know a natural definition for
leakage inside channels then if you use
this as a proxy you could be potentially
under estimating and leakage by an
arbitrarily large factor you with small
alphabet X&Y that's one thing this you
know under our assumption that's full
support this is independent of the
marginal for X right so that means I can
maximize both sides over the marginal
for X here and I just get leakage back
on the right-hand side so maximize both
sides over
the X right and then the point is the
supreme I'm not doing anything
and this is the Shannon capacity so
leakage upper bound is not just mutual
information but also the Shannon
capacity since its px invariant
and when this first came to light I
found this a little bit disconcerting
because with an information theory
review Shannon capacity is like the
ultimate upper bound on how much
information you can get through a
channel the mechanism right that's like
you know even if you're trying to get
information through and you kind of like
code it in the optimum way like this is
the ceiling how much information you can
get through right put it back on
what okay I mean I understand the
statement what you just made yeah that
is only true in the limit over into you
know independent repetitions right and
sometimes even more about than that
going on okay yeah yeah so yeah so I
mean I'm filling up a straw man and I
think you're you're shooting the straw
man I'm about to like really super fit
so yeah I mean so I mean I have
certainly I've encountered the argument
that like you know even if we don't
agree on what the metric is an exact
metric for side channels we know just
use channel capacity right so it's like
the ultimate upper bound right but in
this case it's it's it's under
estimating right so that's a problem
so what's going on so there isn't like
you know an asymptotic you know
difference in kind of formulation to
asymptotes here there's something else
going on too though I think really
explains why we get this ordering so I'd
argue shank capacity is missing
something that we could just capturing
and we can make very precise what it is
missing actually it's excluding certain
s's that this one is not okay so I can
show you so I might need some room for
this so they write leakage in kind of a
funny way
social space here
okay so so first of all I'm gonna the
the guess the adversaries guess when it
has access to why we can just view as
another random variable s hat that just
hangs off the Markov chain like that
right here's a log sorry okay now I'm
gonna manipulate this a little bit so
maximal leakage is additive over
independent copies okay so if i replace
x and y with like nied copies of the
pair like that actually divided by n it
doesn't change okay assuming that we
have you know this full support
assumption this is invariant to the
marginal for X so I can just maximize
over px and let's do anything right and
limit as n goes to infinity that has do
anything either right
this is all just like a very convoluted
way of writing Maxima leakage all right
and here's the claim the shine capacity
I can write in the same way I just add
the constraint that the chance that the
guess is correct has to be at least one
minus Epsilon
and here I take a limit as epsilon goes
to 0
so seems to be a novel way of writing
Shannon capacity I've never seen it
written exactly this way before and it
helps us understand how it relates to
leakage okay so yes Shannon capacity is
asymptotic notion but the term we
another way of looking at this
difference is that in information theory
call capacity the limit of reliable
communication like you know here it's
like you're only looking at S's they can
kind of reliably recover from why and
that's the difference okay so to put a
fine point on it like suppose they're
probably of guessing my password a
priori is 10 to minus 16 and then after
observing why 10 to the minus 1 is that
a problem
or not so maximally kids would say yes
you know 10 to my 16 to 10 to minus 1
that's you know 15 orders of magnitude
increase log base 2 of 10 to 15 that's
you know how many bits you leaking for
that particular s that's potentially a
lot ok shank shank capacity would say no
not a problem okay because you you know
they ever say couldn't guess your
password before and it still can't guess
your password because it's not one
that's what it's missing yes the
difference from the capacity can also be
involved in yes yes
the the error exponent should somehow
explain this I've not a thought thought
about this all in terms of error
exponents yeah I guess they talk about
exponent you have to have kind of a rate
that's different from the capacity like
a rate below capacity and talk about
error probabilities I'm not sure how to
do that
okay can I squeeze in differential
privacy is there okay yeah I have time
all right I don't want to abuse
locations
Barisan with privacy so we have no
notion of databases or sensitivity here
right so the variant of additional
differential privacy you've been
comparing it against is local
differential privacy which you know can
be kind of directly compared to kind of
head-to-head with with this so funny
you're off by 60 years 60 years I beg
your pardon
it's fine okay you said 60 we can tease
it easy later okay this is where I
learned it let me let me maybe I'll say
it that way okay so maximum over X X hat
sorry wherever it came from this is the
definition hopefully you agree on that
okay so the so when I look at this
definition the course that pops in my
head is what is the operational
interpretation of this like this is more
akin to our computable characterization
than our definition right so what would
be the operational definition
underpinning this or you know to put it
in a slightly snarky way like if this is
the answer then what is the question
right
so there is
so if you I did not see an operational
interpretation of this and the paper
that I saw possibly six years ago they
you know they had won the if you go back
to the the the original kind of work at
all virtual privacy paper they give an
operational interpretation for the
original differential privacy definition
and you can map that proof over to this
to give it an operational interpretation
so let me I'm gonna write compare here
okay so this is taking their proof
argument and applying it to this
definition okay so if you like the
result you should credit them if you
think this is like a total
misapplication of their ideas to some
other idea then you can blame blame me
okay so it's maximum overall binary
functions F so all predicates px and
realizations why this absolute value
actually log f of X equals 1 given y
equals y by chance that f of X equals 1
okay that's one way of looking at it
it's this thing in front of the X
underneath Matt it's a PE I'm sorry yeah
this is the it's the distribution for X
oh yeah
just a function of py given X okay so
this is good we can we can also give
another operational interpretation of
this that's kind of more akin to the one
we have for maximum leakage and now for
mutual information okay which is the
following so local differential privacy
so it's take supreme over px introduce
the hidden s
and then we're going to take worst-case
over why realizations
oh sorry I said missus what is f of X
and so it's binary function by
deterministic binary functions of X
like all credits
okay so if you want to compare this to
Maxima leakage the differences here in
here maximum leakage basically just has
an average over lie here and if you have
an average over Y here then it turns out
you don't need this kind of comes for
free so so there's a consequence
local differential privacy upper bounds
so from the you know from this well and
in fact these are equal if and only if
both are 0 so if x and y are independent
they're both are 0 but as long as x and
y are dependent then you'll get okay so
you know again if i when i try to
construct a like an example that cleanly
illustrates the distinction between
these two like you know suppose my
password is a priori hard to guess
probably is like 10 to minus 16 but
suppose there exists one realization of
y so that given that realization of y
it's easy to guess my password but that
one real Y realization has a very low
probability so you know is this a
problem or not so maximally good would
say no local difference privacy would
say yes
depends on the application I'd argue
inside channels you know it's I'm
actually okay with some bad realizations
of Y existing so long as they are
themselves rare ultimately we care about
just the overall probability of guessing
the password so you know how that
conditions and different things is it
doesn't really matter
I'm your hand if we all have our own
kind of interval of the individual data
set and we're gonna apply this mechanism
ourselves individually to it and then
release it you know if some small
fraction of us get this bad realization
of Y that reveals everything then you
know the fact that realization was a
priori unlikely a small consolation or
the fact that like very few of us are in
that bad state is small consolation
right so you know for an application
like that then you know this would make
more sense
okay yeah right mutual information on
the Shannon capacity and did you do that
I didn't see that
and because you're claiming Shannon
capacity is a little bit of sorry what
was the question does she understand why
you argued that Shannon capacity is less
than leakage because I'm capacity
suffice if I give you almost one
probability of correctness is that but
not exactly one so we don't have a
format for mutual information that would
be clearer so it's for a leakage and for
capacity okay so mutual information I
don't know exactly how to write like
this in particular I don't remember I
don't think just deleting that maximum
gives you misinformation yeah
so I don't remember to be on its own
quote me on that but so but anyway let
me just yeah so this is this is formula
for capacity and the idea is the
capacity is like leakage but it's got a
more constrained supremo you're kind of
limited in what s is you can pick by
that condition I can't maximize over as
much aspect is really important
potentially yeah if you look at one-shot
operational right yeah yeah yeah no
you're right I mean my I actually you
know I think this comes this way of
thinking about is really cool so I kind
of gravity to adapt but you're
absolutely right like the the asymptotic
nation notion of it is the aspect of it
is also really important like I don't
know how to get a result like this
relates to two without infinity you know
you can't really so yeah
did I agree with you completely
here's a wrap-up yes stop or did you
mean like save I can I can I can say a
few final words reject news a few point
okay so so well the application I think
is I don't know how to say a few words
about that I guess okay maybe the few
words I can say is we have looked at you
know design mechanisms for this and the
meta theorem is that like adding noise
does not do well under this metric
quantization a lot better so we have
various theorems you know kind of under
different setups that argue that adding
and editing dependent noise is not a
good idea
whereas quantization is I'll just show
you like a kind of a really trivial
example this is the one non discrete
example so if X and z are independent
Gaussian and y equals x plus a Z alright
then we use your next two y's and the
fact is we've nothing special about
gaussian here as long as X is full
support and Z is independent of X then
good infinite so yeah then then it would
not be infinity yeah so it's the fact
that X is infinite support and Z is an
append of X is what gives you infinity
here but if X is bounded support then
get something finite yeah that's true so
like you know but if it has a lot of
support then like adding noise to it
generally not a good idea but if I just
quantize X my around it you know to a
it's like one of n points then the
leakage is the most n so it's like it's
really better so yeah yeah anyway so I
mean we have that's like a very small
example but we have kind of more
sophisticated examples I can you know
talk about with people individually so
you mentioned some some other results
here's for the results on privacy
utility trade-offs like for you know
never say that wants to refer a you know
a receiver that wants to hypothesis test
so this is yeah at all here on that
that's Aleta maybe Flavio and and others
it's a mutual information of other
orders
so this will be part of the next talk so
you can there are other forms the
definition that give you some
utilization of other orders as the
computable characterization and so you
can view maximal leakage is kind of one
point on a spectrum with mutual
information at the other point and a
parameter that kind of seeps between the
the two so what we think we'll talk
about that we've looked at you know with
an information theory a standard set up
to look at the cipher system so you
brahim see that learning from data a
maximal leakage from from realizations
something you and I with that and I'll
just mention to let and with just two
to kind of you know directions to to
work on so one is better composition
theorems alright never you only have
like the most basic composition theorem
it's like if y1 and y2 are independent
looks at X then the leakage from x2 y1
y2 the pair is upper bounded by the sum
of the leakages but you know that's
quite loose especially as you start
looking at more and more looks because
the leakage from X 2 like y1 through yn
is uh provided by log cardinality of X
right so you know where is your your
opera bunch growing linearly and n right
so and I can say from experience have
you tried to apply they'd be really
useful to have like sharper sharper
bounds on that and then another thing
that's come up when we try to apply it I
don't know how doable this is but it
would be helpful to have a version
handle computationally bounded ever
serious so like you know we go to apply
this to like RSA okay and the question
quickly arises like weighted with the
key the public key so the public key is
usually assumed known to everyone if the
public Keys assumes known to everyone
then like you know the adversary just
factors it if it's competition the
unbounded and and that's that game over
right so there's kind of a fundamental
mismatch between our metric which
assumes a computationally unbounded
adversary and you know the cryptographic
side channels like an RSA where you know
it's all based on a computationally
bounded
you know in this assumption so you can
kind of skirt this to some extent just
pretend the key doesn't exist or the
public key doesn't exist still the
bounds of you get from applying maximum
leakage can be quite loose because
they're just looking at what
statistically as possible not what's
kinda gation aliy possible so anyway it
would be useful to have I don't know you
know how feasible that is but I can say
it would be useful all right no I will
stop thank you
[Applause]
okay